direction à présent Hélène le nouveau
centre de tri interdépartemental de
parsémêlé oui l'équipement encore en
rodage doit progressivement prendre la
suite du centre de tri de la grange
d'avide à la riche devenu trop petit à
terme 53000 tonnes d'emballages et de
papiers en provenance de l'indréloire du
loirécher et de la Sarte y seront
traités visite guidée d'une partie des
100000 m car avec Clémence
Dosque c'est dans ces cinq silos que le
contenu de nos poubelles jaune débutent
son voyage déposé sur un tapis roulant
les déchets sont acheminés jusqu'au
crible balistique pour une première
séparation des déchets creux comme les
bouteilles de ceux qui sont plats le tri
s'effectue ensuite de plus en plus
sévèrement au fil des machines papier
carton épais plastique ou cartonnette
l'infrastructure est en capacité de les
différencier le cur du système consiste
à trier les déchets de manière optique
de manière à bien séparer les papiers et
des différents autres plastiques et
autres déchets et vous voyez ici un
triilleur optique qui permet de séparer
les produits qui arrivent sur le triur
optique qui sont accéléré et par
spectrométrie on reconnaît la matière
qui permet de séparer de manière
quasiment parfaite des bouteilles de PET
du reste du déchet pour ensuite envoyer
les Pet vers les le le propre filière de
valorisation en fin de chaîne in tri est
effectué à la main 17 salariés vérifient
le travail des machines et éliminent les
éventuels déchets non pris en charge ici
appelés des refus
ce qui peut être revalorisé est ensuite
compressé sous forme de balle avant
d'être racheté par les filières
adéquates afin de connaître les
performances de tri des habitants d'une
collectivité un échantillon est
régulièrement analysé le taux de refus
s'élève pour le moment à près de 30 %
trival de Loire espère le voir baisser
sous la barre des 20 % d'ici les
prochaines
années